- Oh, my gosh.
Nice to see you.
- How are you?
- I am so good.
- [Michael] You look amazing.
- I know.
Hey, at least we're not in virtual.
- [Michael] Exactly.
- And we have an audience.
- [Michael] Absolutely.
- It's amazing.
- [Michael] How are you?
- I know.
- How are you?
- We're so good.
I'm so happy that we have an
audience back, but congrats.
So you became a doctor
since I last saw you?
Is this true?
- Yes, yes I did.
- Okay.
(crowd applauds)
You should've brought like, glasses.
- I am, I was... it's so funny.
I got this honorary doctorate
from speaking at Dillard university.
So shout out to Dillard
university, I appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the opportunity.
It was a magical experience.
Like I think there was
a lot of nerves in terms
of making a speech, obviously, but-
- Oh, that would terrify me.
- Yeah, it's terrifying.
It is terrifying, but it
was like an opportunity
to kind of you know, help
these kids out and tell 'em
you know, kind of what's awaiting them
now that they're done with school
and the best part was
meeting some of the graduates
who had to stop,
go have a baby, go-
- Life happened.
- You know, life happened
and then they come back
and they finished and we all
know how hard it is to finish.
So all those people,
shout out to those people
- Way to follow through.
- who really pushed through
to get it done, yeah.
- Yeah, it's exciting probably
too, to just talk to them
and your whole future's
ahead of you, you know?
What's an exciting thing.
What did you study when
you were in college?
- I was an English major.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay, wow.
- I was an English major
but that was kind of by
default because I... (laughs)
- That's by default?
- By default, yeah
because I went to college
as an architecture major.
Yeah, there was a lot of math and science.
(Kelly laughs)
- You were like, I am really into reading.
- In architecture so I
had to kind of pivot.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Architecture
is so cool though.
- Architecture is amazing.
- Especially when done so well,
especially go to like Europe
you see all these just old buildings
that have been there for years and years.
Like, it's beautiful.
- Yes, I fell deeply in love
with architecture as a kid
and then, you know, when I got to college
I realized I might not have
everything it takes to do it.
So I had to pivot and I
was always pretty good
at reading and writing so I chose English
and it worked out for me.
- That's the thing about
college that I think is fun.
You go in thinking one thing
and then your whole, you
know, trajectory could change.
You should read Pillars of the
Earth, it's by Ken Follett,
but anyway it's about
how they built, you know,
cathedrals right, but
those people that started
those cathedrals never saw
it to fruition obviously
'cause it took like
hundreds of years, right?
Anyway, a it's really cool
thing if you like building.
- I do.
- So do you still like building things?
Are you like, the guy that's handy
that does stuff around the house?
- Yeah. I... In my head, yeah.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- That's different.
- I am amazing in my head.
- You're like Tim "the tool man" Taylor?
- I'm superior to Tim "the
tool man" Taylor in my head.
(audience claps)
I really fancy myself as the kind of guy
who can fix things and will,
you know, take that approach
and to my kids, if there's
a toy that's broken?
- You fix it, see?
- Dad can fix anything, anything.
- Let's say I was interviewing
your wife right now.
What do you think she would say? (laughs)
You're like, is she coming out?
- You know how that happens, you know.
You gotta make sure.
- No, no, no, no, no.
I just bet she has a different story.
She's like, he will try and
fix everything. (laughs)
- She will say what I... I
mean, she'll say, you know,
he gets some of it done,
he gets some of it done
- [Kelly] (laughs) Love it.
but most of the time
he has to call somebody
for some of the big stuff.
- You know what though?
- [Michael] The little things, I can-
- That's a grown human,
that knows when you need to call someone.
- Yeah, and if you need a spider
swatted, I'm that guy too.
- Yeah I can do that too, yeah.
What's the coolest
thing you've ever built?
Or that you felt maybe not
the coolest, but you're like
this was really hard and I did it?
- So I'm a huge fan of Ikea furniture.
- [Kelly] Oh my.
(audience laughs)
- Now see, that is where
friendships can go wrong.
Putting together that furniture,
if you survive it, you will make it.
- It makes you a stronger person, Kelly.
It makes you a stronger person.
I feel like I have a degree in it now.
I feel like I have an
honorary doctorate in it now.
However, my crowning
achievement, I built my daughter
a dollhouse for Christmas,
I think a year ago.
Just over a year ago, like 2020.... 2020
and so at about 12 o'clock
at night, I started.
- Oh no.
- I didn't have a choice.
Had to get 'em down, had
to wrap by the gifts.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- 12 o'clock I started,
I wrapped around 4:30.
But guys, the key was tequila.
- I was gonna say, I was gonna
say what were you drinking?
(laughs)
- Couple glasses of tequila.
- Literally every parent, no
matter how much you prepare.
I have everything almost done,
but there's always something
that happens like that night
and I'm like, how did this
slip through the cracks?
- How come this wasn't all done?
- Yeah, it's true.
- I should be going to bed.
Yes, you would think you
would know that at that point,
I mean, she was maybe three
or four when that happened.
But the joy that she got out
of that house was, I mean,
she still plays with it almost every day.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And so that is my crowning achievement.
It was a three, no four story plus attic.
It's the biggest house I've ever seen.
- I have built many a
playhouse, dollhouse things
with a friend that's really good at it
and we love each other so we survive it.
Congrats on the series, I loved it.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I binge watched it.
I kind of, I hated all of you the next day
'cause I had to be at work.
I was actually interviewing Kristen
and I was like "I am so
tired because of you."
Like, because I couldn't stop.
I was like, maybe I'll try.
I'm a mom, you know, I got kids.
I'm like, I gotta go to bed,
put in bed, all these things
and I was like, okay I'll
watch a little bit of it,
as much as I can.
I could not stop watching it.
- Good.
It's so good.
- Thank you.
- It's funny but it's also
like, y'all are really good.
So like I get that it's a satire,
but it's also just like really good.
Anyway, the glasses or the Clark Kent look
is a really good look for you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I just need to say.
Yeah.
(crowd clapping)
Yeah, hey! (laughs)
You got a shout out from Jessie.
No, but for those who haven't seen it,
first of all, don't start it
unless you wanna watch it all
because it's one of those.
You're not gonna be able to stop watching.
It's not like a "I'll catch it next time."
You're gonna need to watch it all.
But if for those who haven't seen it
tell everybody what it's about.
- So it's a satire that
is basically satirizing
the psychological thriller
that you keep seeing, you know.
Like The Mayor of East
Town and The Undoing
and all of those movies.
So we're doing like the
Naked Gun version of that
and it is like... it is unbelievably funny
but so many people are confusing it
with a real psychological thriller.
- [Kelly] That's true!
- Because we intentionally
did this like whereby
we're playing it so dead
pan that you do care
about who killed the
girl... in the window...
- Across the street.
- From the other girl in that window.
- A wife in the house, or my ex-wife in...
and so you find yourself really wanting
to know who did it, but
at the same time like,
the list of suspects is just,
I mean, one after the other
and my favorite is Tom Riley's character.
I mean, he just, he brought
out the... you know,
out of the trunk.
- [Kelly] It's so good.
It was like, I mean bawling laughing.
- Like I was laughing so hard
'cause it was so unbelievable.
When Kristen was here I asked if
she's spied on her neighbors.
So have you ever sped on your neighbors?
- Absolutely.
- You have?
(crowd laughs)
- I don't think anybody...
there's no, come on.
- You know what?
I don't know if this is like...
- If you live close enough to
somebody else or you've ever
lived in a major city and
you're like in a higher,
or you're in a hotel in
the middle of the city
and you're looking out the window?
- I love that you just told
us all the things you've done.
- Exactly, these are all
the places I've spied.
I've spied, I'm not ashamed
of it, we all do it, it's-
- No, here's the thing, am
I like, super egocentric?
'Cause I've never done that, I've never-
- Come on!
- No, I've never... I
don't know if I've cared.
I don't know if I've-
- You don't have to care,
it's just the opportunity presents itself.
- I think if I saw... (laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- Right?
Or you'll just be in a hotel,
like you're high up in a hotel
and you look out the
window to see the view
and then you see somebody
walk across the window
and you're like, look away.
(crowd laughs)
Look away.
You know what I mean?
and you don't know, what did I just see?
- I don't think I've ever
had anything interesting.
- I can see right into
their bathroom, oh wow.
I should probably close this.
- [Kelly] I should probably... (laughs)
- I should probably close, room service?
- You know what though, if they're going
and they're doing their
business with God and everyone
being able to see, that's their problem.
- I mean, you know and let
me... I have seen some stuff.
(Kelly laughs)
- I've never seen anything, I
don't think I've ever noticed.
I don't know, I'm very focused.
- Some people are
exhibitionists in that way,
you know what I mean?
- Oh, you know, I'm the
person y'all are looking at.
(laughs)
I'm just figuring out who I am, sorry.
- You're the one that gets spied on.
- I'm the one that gets spied on,
that's why I, yes, it's fine
Look, it's my house, if you're
watching that's your problem.
I wanted to ask though about your kids,
so that your daughter is
giving you a music education?
Is this happening?
- [Michael] Yeah.
- How so?
- I'm weak, I'm so weak
for her, it's so bad.
Like I taught her some old
school music that I grew up on
and I hoped that she would enjoy,
so I introduced her to like,
Candy Girl by New Edition.
Right? And you know, the
highlight of my year last year
is she got into the car and she said,
"Daddy can you play Candy Girl?"
I was just like, "Yeah,
I got you, I got you."
(Kelly laughs)
- And then she asked for like,
Blank Space and you know,
other songs and so,
- [Kelly] Oh, Taylor.
Yeah, and so in my car it'll play that
and then it'll play other
songs in that genre, right?
And a lot, some of your music comes up.
- Yeah, and some pop, yeah.
- So it's amazing because
I'll drop her off at school
and then I'll get back in
the car and I am singing
full throttle to like,
Ariana Grande's The Way
and I'll stop at a light and
I'm jamming and I'll look over
and the person is looking
at me and I'm like-
- [Kelly] That's right, that's right.
- I used to be a sex symbol,
I'm sorry, I used to be cool
but I love this music,
I don't know what it is
but it makes my daughter smile and happy
so it works for me.
- And it reminds me of...
So I drop my kids off
and they like to listen
to Encanto right now,
the whole sound track.
- Oh, that movie's incredible.
- It's so incredible.
So like, I drop them off
and I get back in the car,
- [Man] Bruno.
- I'm still listening to it
and I'm like sitting there
doing Bruno while people
are out there like yeah,
that's right, I'm singing it.
- I'm singin' Bruno all day.
- It's so good!
I do it too, we all do it.
So wait, you coach your son's football.
How do you have time to coach
your son's football league?
- Aw, yeah, that was fun, that was fun.
My first time coaching, my
first time coaching ever.
- And it was fun, not stressful?
- It was stressful at times for sure,
'cause they're eight year olds
so they will they're drive you crazy.
Yeah, it was definitely stressful.
But they ended up, your short story is
they ended up winning everything.
They won the Super Bowl.
- It's probably 'cause of your coaching.
- They won the Super Bowl, which was like,
well this is a damn good start, right?
Like, as a coach so I consider myself
the Bill Belichick of flag football.
- (laughs) I was like, you take credit.
- I take credit for that and you know,
they beat the team that beat
them twice in the Super Bowl.
- Oh wow, what a great story!
- Yeah, yeah.
I made some defensive
adjustments and I think that's
what led to the title
- You were MVP.
- And my son, who wasn't
the best player on the team
played his best games in the
playoffs and the Super Bowl
and everything, when it counted.
And so the next morning
I had to fly to Chicago.
He was so happy, he was
holding up his trophy.
His slept with his trophy.
The next morning I left
him a little letter,
oh man, telling him how proud I was.
- Oh, that's so nice!
- Yeah, 'cause he showed
up when it counted most.
- Yeah, I love that
and I love that y'all got
that bonding experience.
Not everybody... not
every parent has the time
to do that, that's amazing.
- Exactly, and now I'm retired
'cause I want to go out on top.
- Yeah. (laughs) I nailed it.
- I won't be coming back.
- Yeah, (laughs) just a one and done-r.